[Música]
en la asamblea general de la ONU Rusia
se alineó con China y aseguró que
Estados Unidos juega con fuego al
avanzar en sus relaciones con la isla de
Taiwán y que Beijing reclama como propia
este último gobierno aseguró que
respalda una salida negociada a la
Guerra de Ucrania
la policía rusa restó a más de 730
personas en medio de las protestas
contra los reclutamientos anunciados por
Vladimir Putin para continuar la guerra
en Ucrania las manifestaciones son
crecientes mientras que los últimos
reportes muestran que Moscú Sigue
perdiendo terreno en el conflicto
al menos 41 muertos dejan las masivas
protestas en Irán por el caso de maxa
amini que murió bajo custodia policial
después de ser arrestada por llevar mal
puesto el pelo las ong dicen que los
fallecidos son más de 50 el presidente
ibrahimsy dijo que tratará con decisión
a quienes se opongan a la seguridad y
tranquilidad del país
Hola Bienvenidos a un nuevo Informativo
en francés 24 los saluda Andrés Meza
Muñoz comenzamos las noticias en Nueva
York que Estados Unidos en la asamblea
general de la ONU este sábado las
intervenciones de Rusia y China versaron
sobre la política entre Estados Unidos y
Taiwán y sobre lo que el ministro de
exteriores ruso calificó como rusofobia
que está instigando occidente de otra
parte china dijo que apoya una salida
negociada a la guerra en Ucrania Andrés
granadillo con los detalles una
intervención esperada en la asamblea
general de la ONU el ministro de
exteriores rusos serguéi labrov acusó a
occidente del odio generalizado hacia
Rusia
la rusofobia oficial en occidente ha
alcanzado una escala grotesca sin
precedentes no escatiman en declarar su
intención de infringir una derrota
militar a nuestro país pero también de
destruir y fracturar a Rusia
además aprovechó para defender la guerra
en Ucrania que inició el 24 de febrero
la incapacidad de los países
occidentales para negociar y la la
última guerra del régimen de kiev contra
su propio pueblo no nos dejaron otra
opción la dependencia sobre la República
Popular de Indonesia y lugans e iniciar
una operación militar especial para
proteger al pueblo Ruso y a otros
pueblos del vaso la broma arremetió
contra las decisiones de política
internacional de Washington por ejemplo
la independencia de Taiwán y les
advirtió que jugaban con fuego china en
su intervención reiteró los derechos que
dice tener sobre la isla
desde la antigüedad Taiwán ha sido una
parte inseparable del territorio de
China la soberanía y la integridad
territorial de China nunca han sido
cortadas y el hecho de que la parte
continental y Taiwán pertenezcan a una
misma china nunca ha cambiado todos los
chinos nunca hemos dejado de esforzarnos
por realizar la reunificación en cuanto
a la guerra en Ucrania el ministro de
exteriores chino dijo que su país apoya
a los esfuerzos para buscar una
resolución pacífica del conflicto
en Rusia este sábado la fuerza pública
detuvo más de 730 personas en las
protestas contra la movilización militar
parcial según la ong obd info las
manifestaciones se producen en 32
ciudades distintas recordemos que el
decreto anunciado el miércoles por el
presidente Vladimir Putin supone el
envío de 300.000 reservistas al frente
en Ucrania y es el primer reclutamiento
obligatorio en Rusia desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial la orden llegó después de
que el parlamento ruso endureciera la
represalias por desertar del ejército y
en un momento en que la crítica a las
fuerzas armadas puede implicar penas de
cárcel en Irán el presidente Ibrahim
raicy advirtió que tratará con decisión
a quienes se opongan a la seguridad y
tranquilidad del país la televisión
Estatal iraní afirma que 41 personas han
muerto en las manifestaciones pero las
ong elevan las cifras 54 la muerte de
amini por el uso incorrecto del velo ha
provocado la indignación mundial de
muchos miembros de la diáspora iraní en
todo el mundo celebraron protestas este
sábado
siguiendo El ejemplo de las mujeres de
Irán estas manifestantes en la capital
griega se cortaron el pelo en protesta
por el estricto código de vestimenta del
régimen para las mujeres se unen a un
movimiento que se inició después de que
Max samini de 22 años falleciera tras
ser detenida por la policía de la moral
y de anís
me estoy cortando el pelo porque muchas
de mis hermanas en Irán van a morir
Quizás mañana por culpa del jillaf y yo
no lo quiero y lo odio y no quiero
seguir a este régimen terrorista y
dictatorial
[Aplausos]
es un sentimiento del que se han hecho
eco la diáspora iraní en protestas por
toda Europa el sábado cientos de
personas acudieron a esta manifestación
en Berlín donde algunas manifestantes
dicen que casi corrieron la misma suerte
Trágica que a Minnie
una situación similar cuando tenía 16
años tuve suerte de que no me partieran
la cabeza pero he vivido la misma
violencia y no vamos a permitir que esto
vuelva a ocurrir en cualquier parte del
mundo no queremos eso
junto a los retratos de amín y las
manifestantes en Suecia mostraron fotos
de otras supuestas víctimas del régimen
iraní yo soy este régimen debe irse por
todas las masacres que hicieron en 40
años en Irán
intentamos llegar a los políticos de
Suecia y de otros países es lo único que
podemos hacer aquí
[Aplausos]
mientras que las protestas se
intensifican en Irán en el vecino Irak
decenas de personas inundaron las calles
de hervir la muerte de aminia ha tocado
la fibra sensible de estas manifestantes
muchas de las cuales proceden de la
parte iraní del kurdistán la región
natal de
Fuertes lluvias cerca de la capital de
India han provocado inundaciones masivas
y daños en la ciudad suburbana de guru
gram al sur de Nueva Delhi el clima
extremo sigue azotando hacia ya que el
Monzón trae lluvias cada vez más
intensas e irregulares a la región con
un aspecto más parecido al de las
piscinas que al de las carreteras
desplazarse por la ciudad de burucrán se
ha convertido en algo difícil y
peligroso nadar no es un problema solo
hay que tener cuidado de no tragar agua
de lluvia saltos niveles de agua están
provocando atascos haciendo que sea casi
imposible circular por algunas calles
ha llovido sin parar las alcantarillas
están completamente llenas
has dañado las carreteras hay agua en
los baches
es muy difícil llegar a la oficina
las escuelas están cerradas y las
autoridades han pedido a aquellos que
puedan que trabajen desde casa las
lluvias monzónicas son especialmente
fuertes en India y en el resto del sur
de Asia pero en los últimos años el
clima se ha vuelto más intenso e
impredecible los expertos dicen que está
relacionado con el calentamiento global
mientras que la mala planificación
urbana junto con el aumento de la
población en las ciudades hace que las
inundaciones anuales causen cada vez más
estragos en las infraestructuras y en
los medios de vida de los habitantes
Corea del Sur informó sobre un nuevo
lanzamiento de un misil balístico no
identificado por parte de Corea del
Norte aunque no especificó más detalles
al respecto como el alcance O cuál fue
su trayectoria se trata del primer
evento de este tipo desde junio cuando
los norcoreanos lanzaron 8 misiles
balísticos de corto alcance ese
lanzamiento se produce después de la
llegada de un portaaviones
estadounidense a territorio surcoreano
para participar de simulacros conjuntos
y antes de la visita de la
vicepresidenta a kamala Harris prevista
para la próxima semana
realizó la edición número 70 del
Festival Internacional de Cine de San
Sebastián uno de los 15 mayores
festivales de la temporada la gran
ganadora de la jornada fue la colombiana
Los reyes del mundo que se llevó la
concha de oro a mejor película nuestra
corresponsable Madrid Marina Colorado
nos amplía la información gran noche
para el cine latinoamericano en la
entrega de premios del festival de cine
de San Sebastián desde el público hasta
el Jurado premiaron al cine del
continente con cinco de los 14 premios
principales del certamen Empezando por
el del público que premió a Argentina
1985 de Santiago mitre una película
inspirada en el juicio a las juntas
proceso contra el órgano militar de la
dictadura Argentina para el productor
del filme recibir el premio del público
para una película que trata sobre la
defensa de la Democracia resulta
doblemente hermoso el premio Horizonte
es a la mejor cinta latinoamericana fue
para tengo sueños eléctricos de
Valentina maurel la costarricense en su
discurso pidió que este premio sirva
para que el presidente Rodrigo Chávez
reconsidere los recortes por supuesto de
cultura en su país la joven Argentina
por su parte Renata lerman con tan solo
12 años Recibió la concha de plata a la
mejor interpretación de reparto y
Argentina también se llevó el premio del
Jurado a la mejor fotografía que recibió
Manuel abramovich por la película porno
melancolía pero la corona del festival
la concha de oro La Recibió la película
colombiana Los reyes del mundo de la
directora Laura Mora es la primera vez
en la 70 ediciones que una cinta
colombiana se lleva el gran premio Y el
tercer año consecutivo en el que gana un
filme dirigido por una mujer en su
cuenta de Twitter celebran que para los
reyes del mundo esto ha sido un viaje en
busca de la tierra prometida que no
podría acabar mejor
cerramos en Argentina porque el gobierno
tuvo que intervenir para encontrar una
solución a la escasez de los famosos
stickers coleccionables y álbumes del
mundial de Qatar 2022 el ministro de
comercio convocó a una reunión el
próximo martes con la empresa encargada
de los derechos de los productos del
fabricante y miembros del sindicato
nacional de comerciantes los llamados
quiosqueros que tradicionalmente venden
el álbum culpan a la compañía de
priorizar a otros establecimientos
también se quejan de que los
distribuidores locales no están
respetando los precios oficiales lo que
impide que muchos fanáticos del fútbol
coleccionen a sus figuras favoritas
de esta manera despedimos este
Informativo en France 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]